this year Gregory Peck turned producer
again and he brought us a very poetic
film we called the Dove the story was a
variation on the classic romantic theme
a boy girl and a boat tonight the boat
is in drydock but we have the girl and
the boy with us ladies and gentlemen
Miss Deborah Rothman and mr. Joseph
bottoms
okay with apologies to Cole Porter but
if I'm the bottoms well you're the top
you know the nominations for the best
achievement and sound are bud grins Bach
and Larry Jost
for Chinatown Walter Murch and Arthur
Rochester for the conversation
Ronald Pierce and Melvin Metcalf senior
for earthquake Theodore Soderbergh and
Herman Lewis for the towering inferno
Richard Portman and gene can't tamasa
for Young Frankenstein and the winner is
Ronald Pierce another Metcalf senior
well I thank all the people that worked
on this
to do this use directors the men that
perfected sense around especially Jack
Bolger Mel Metcalfe's jr. and Ted met
John Mack I'm rather nervous thank you I
think Ronnie has said about as much as I
can say except I would like to thank the
crew that worked me it with me on
production Jack Danskin and Billy Morris
and I want to thank the Academy